did you see mark hamill reading Donald
Trump's tweet as the Joker yeah did you
hear it I did not but I would probably I
know sometimes there's a better choice
here it
yeah because mark hamill is well not
mark Hamill's well known as the voice of
the Joker like he's beloved there are
people who known as the voice of the
Joker more than as Luke Skywalker before
declare some people who think that he's
the best Joker
yes ever what'd he do it very popular
opinion for the animated series yeah he
did it for Batman the Animated Series
and you did it fer I was wondering why
he was doing that okay he did it for for
many many years okay
and there are that's it that's a debate
like it's Cesar Romero that's his name
right yep the first Joker yeah I didn't
Millan Cesar Millan he was the Batman
Whisperer Cesar Romero Jack Nicholson
Heath Ledger he legend did it he did it
yeah and am i that's right and Mark
Hamill people loved Mark Hamill was I
never heard no idea - you said that he
read Donald Trump's Happy New Year's
tweet as the Joker happy New Year to all
including to my many enemies and those
who have fought me and lost so that was
really good Jim and that night that
wasn't you don't think that was good no
go back to it have to read the tweet it
wasn't it wasn't that good yeah I did
wait do you have something else yeah you
think you could be done better better
Joker yes no and so hey drew you bummed
that we didn't do this yesterday Happy
New Year Batman including to all my many
enemies
and those who have fought me and lost so
badly they just don't know what to do
love that man he didn't even read it
right good you know you don't want to
actually love to hear I would love to
hear the Joker read Donald Trump's Meryl
Streep tweet that's what I think
I love it I loved it for the Joker
to sound off on on on Meryl Streep's
opinion of Donald Trump and everything
that happened okay you want the Joker to
do it I would like to hear what the
Joker would say metal step one of the
most operated actresses in Hollywood
doesn't know me but attacked me last
night at the Golden Globes she is a dot
dot dot dot there's another tweet be the
one above it I wanna I'm done
all right well thanks for doing that
chip I thought we were gonna do a
different thing oh there's a joker
that was it didn't sound like the Jesse
jokes